[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen den männerchor
welt bei uns zu hause gibt es gleich
frühstück und mag es bei uns eine
türkische also meine freundin würde
türkisches eierspeis also ein türkisches
frühjahr mit gericht erspart habe ich
allerdings auch vorher gehört aber es
half mir dazu gelernt und zwar etwas
vegetarisches klar wenn jetzt der rat
mit dabei wäre da kommt auch gleich sagt
natürlich wieder stanley macht peter
stripp mit rein aber wir halten das
heute wirklich vegetarisch und zwar
kommen da zwiebeln mit reinen peperoni
und tomaten und es ist so ein richtig
leckeres früher was ist eigentlich bei
uns im türkischen frühstück immer gibt
also das ist immer mit dabei und das
kennt eigentlich jeder und ich denke
jeder macht es auch auf die gleiche art
und weise zumindest habe ich das von
meiner mama gelernt und ich zeige euch
mal ganz kurz die wenige zutaten also
ich brauch bisschen olivenöl dann ein
paar tomaten ne zwiebel etwas
paprikaschoten also ich habe jetzt hier
auf türkisch sagt da charlize theron die
türken gesprächen des wasserschadens uns
also nicht strafe und ich habe ich auch
noch ein paar schafe und ein paar als
ich habe hier fünf eier und das ist die
menge die wohnsitze für etwa vier bis
fünf personen ausreicht und natürlich
einfach paar gewürze deshalb
pfefferminze und thymian und das war es
eigentlich schon ich komme direkt
startet heute ist bei uns besuch heute
gibt es nämlich zum frühstück er heute
gibt's nicht so frühstück heute zum
frühstück ich die caribo meter weiter
ist auch gleich da und da gibt es bei
uns halt echte muss nur richtig tolles
türkisches frühstück bei seiner karrie
motto das schon mal hatte ich so ein
türkisches berichtet hat sony und zu
wenig auch gespannt weil das können fans
jetzt auch wissen wir frühstücken ja
nicht immer süß ach so na ja und zwar
ziemlich deftig genau also eigentlich
frühstücken wir wenn wir drehen meistens
süß wobei ich immer so ein mix zwischen
süß und deftig ja stimmt aber so dass
nutella brot da ich ja das könnte man
dazu das kann auch hier heute mit dazu
also muss auf jeden fall scheint es auf
jeden fall alles in würfel als ich jetzt
erstmal die zwiebel einfach in würfel
muss jetzt auch mit mega sorgfältig sein
ich finde schmeckt halt besser wenn es
kleiner gewürfelt ich hatte auch gleich
mit einem
mit der peperoni zone mit einer tomate
bin ich schön wenn alles schön fein
gewürfelt ist jetzt ist so üblich in der
türkei also so deftig schon den tag zu
beginnen oder jahr wobei in der türkei
also ich habe auch noch nicht so ein
video gesehen war ganz witzig wo ist
denn hier ist es so sie deutsches
frühstück aussieht italienisches
frühstück aus und es sieht französisches
aus viele essen entweder salzig oder süß
aber bei den türken ist schon so
eigentlich gibt es da alles also man ist
wirklich alles es geht dann aber so
deftige gerichte bis über 2000 pacman es
gibt zum beispiel es ist samira ganz
gern das ist einfach diese sesampaste
mit bisschen trauben sirup sehr lecker
also empfehle ich jedem vor allem ist es
in der türkei so ein bisschen medizin
einsatz dieser trauben sehr hoch sagt
mir immer wenn man zu wenig blut im
körper hat so man das wissen was hier
gibt es den kindern immer ja schon viel
eisen mit drin
die türken die essen alles bei uns gibt
es immer alles so und jetzt gebe ich
direkt schon mal die zwiebeln in eine
pfanne gibt da auch gleich oliven
irgendwie dazu da kommen jetzt noch etwa
drei bis vier esslöffel mit rein und
lass das jetzt ganze schon mal etwas
anbraten als douglas ich dünsten und die
zeit nutzt sich dann um die
paprikaschoten einfach klein zu
schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die paprika stücke
einfach mit rein geben ich hoffe es
werden dazu scharf wobei karim und nicht
vergessen beide ganz gern scharf
demokratisch das ein bisserl
empfindlicher wobei morath 12
ja ich habe jetzt diesen kindergarten
gebracht die wäsche aufgehängt und den
müll rausgebracht dieses halten ehemann
oder ist es doch ein elfer ja sowieso
sein mir ist ganz schlecht
berlin halt bevor du weiter reduziert
die paprika stücke ja mit rein geht
jetzt einfach den deckel drauf und dann
kann so ein bisserl weiter bisserl
dünnste und während der murat jetzt
gleich redet kann ich nämlich schon mal
die tore hatten einfach kleinstück
kannst du dich so so reimer bitte ich
habe zwar heute machen dass vegetarier
aber ich bin in man jetzt bitte ich kann
s rechnet mich vor allem das nächste mal
aber es tut mir drei machen möchte muss
es einfach mit den zwiebeln zusammen
anbraten von gemüse schrumpfte bizeps
ich brate das gleiche separat mit an
man gibt es auch so zu kommen da kann
man schon mal den tisch richtig gemacht
dass er kurzzeitig wer soll's richten
kann es sich karima karima de steht mit
mir her der kamera ich richte keine
tische
was ich machen will macht die frau mache
die technik und nur kurze tisch
[Musik]
bin ich soweit das gemüse des
ausschusses gehen gleich die tomaten mit
dazu und das ganze wird es nochmal so
etwa 23 minuten gekostet
einfach das wird dann so großartig und
durch das dann gleich gebunden und was
ihr an der stelle jetzt schon mal machen
könnt ihr könnt es jetzt auch schon mal
würzen mit salz und pfeffer
da nicht so viel sparen denn die eier
kommen noch hinzu
ich habe meine kindheit ist hat meine
mutter natalia wenige mikrometer
gemeinte einer mauer
naja wenn die kamera heraus wer jetzt
anders gesagt stimmt gar jetzt noch
etwas thymian und minze und während das
heben auch vor sich hin kocht muss noch
durch kann ich schon mal die eier
aufschlagen und im schnee beta verklären
[Musik]
das sind übrigens die grüne eier von
murats arbeitskollegen
also da hat so ein kleiner bauernhof in
hat ganz viele hühner und er wird uns
nur mit gras
jetzt denke ich glaube meist reger die
aber durch einfach so eine spezielle
hühnerrasse und anscheinend als das ist
nicht bewiesen aber angeblich sollen
diese eier weniger kohle studiert haben
das liegt an dieser rasse die adac
münchen kuchen braun mit was mit musste
schon liegt und zwar die eier vom
bauernhof die sind einfach das ist
einfach viel geld also da war mein
biskuit teig richtig gelb gar kein salz
habe sogar früher kennt oder saft dann
mach den kuchen gehen hier bei richtiger
aufgabe als recht praktisch anno stand
immer mehr farbe
nach 23 minuten und dann gleich fertig
und murat ich bereit sondern auch schon
mal hier den zugverkehr gibt es
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da gibt es ja auch unterschiedliche
geschmacksrichtungen
also wir mögen diese rote ist als aus
aus 100 prozent rindfleisch und dies
scharf und dann gibt es ja noch die
grüne
das heißt die grüne wurst sondern ich
bin einfach fortschreiben lässt halt aus
geflügel hat auch weniger fett genau
aber ist nicht so unser fall mehr so
schmeckt zwar auch aber schmeckt so
genau was cool ist ja immer gesagt dann
springt er genau das ist ganz ganz
wichtig aber es gibt wirklich leute die
das ding brille zum beispiel ist das
grillen und dieser nicht wieso haupt ran
lassen
man musste immer drüber lachen
wir sind also ich lustig wenn mir das
jemand schreibt oder auch in der pfanne
an das habe ich auch schon oft gesehen
dass man manche leute öl oder oder oder
oder oder verein macht es braucht man es
braucht man endlich wieder ein eigenfett
das heißt einfach angefangen und kurz
anbraten und so eine männerrolle murat
wäre einfach zu dick einpacken
ja ich sage immer wenn wir das kennt
dann will mir gar nichts mehr anderes
testen
[Musik]
so ich sind auch die tomaten weich hoch
hier dampfbremse und jetzt kann ich hier
die eier bezug geben und das ganze
beginnt jetzt gleich zu stoppen
einfach schön durchrühren und ich mag
das auch wenn es dann noch nicht so ganz
fest ich also wenn es einfach so ein
bisschen ruhe bleibt dann ist es nicht
so trocken wobei trocken wird wegen den
tomaten aber so bist ja ein bisschen
weich dass bei mir noch sein
und da kommt halt auch richtig gut mir
leid' frische kräuter mit reingeht und
mir fällt freilich hat schnittlauch auf
der terrasse ich glaube ich geheult mal
stück noch mit rein
das mache ich gleich ich glaube dass
gleich die karima ganz kurz
[Musik]
an der stelle mache ich jetzt im herz
bereits ausland jetzt ist das ganze
schön durch gegart und zieht einfach mit
der wärme ab so tückisch auch gleich
fertig dann haben wir beides abgedeckt
ich habe meine vegetarisches früher ein
und er hat seinen job
ich mag auch so druck aber nicht immer
also bei mir muss fleisch hat immer sein
ich frühstücke meistens vegetarisch
jetzt hole ich schnell die teller zum
anrichten und zeige mich dann gleich das
ende geht
also bei mir ist es so ich glaube dass
immer mit der pfanne auf den tisch damit
es einfach nicht kalt wird und schön
warm bleibt und dann kann sich jeder am
tisch einfach so bitte was ausschöpfen
und auf die teller gebe
[Musik]
frischkäse und feta käse und oliven ist
das so für mich das perfekte frühstück
und schmeckt uns allen immer sehr gut so
und wir genießen es jetzt gleich noch
mal
deswegen mache ich jetzt noch ganz
schnell fertig ihr dürft das rezept
natürlich nachlesen auf der leeze
blog.de und wenn ihr gerne weitere so
frühstücks ideen haben wollt schreibt
mir einfach in die kommentare
sie hat nämlich noch ganz viele leckere
rezepte noch ganz viele andere türkische
spezialitäten vor allem fürs frühstück
denn ich finde das frühstück ist
eigentlich die wichtigste mahlzeit am
tag deswegen ist es bei uns immer so ein
richtig großer großes ereignis und wird
bei uns immer also ja mit uns an viel
zeit fürs frühstück
ich schaue mich die ich hoffe ihr nehmt
euch auch viel zeit und jetzt wünsche
ich euch noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen falls ihr es nach macht und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
besser
[Musik]